I watched a video from the Cancer Center for Healied Irvo
Channel, Florida, called Healing with Voltage, or Dr. Jerry
Teddett, was interviewed. The theme was that all cells have
voltage or charge. The minimum to maintain health is 25
microvolts. And 50 microvolts is needed to heal when cells get
up down to five microvolts. The polarity could actually slip
resulted in serious disease, including cancer. Dr. Teddett
has designed a bio-modulator to correct polarity and a biobio
charger to raise cell voltage. Are you familiar with this
treatment center and with these therapies? Are they worth
looking into the treatments? I have been receiving good not
seem to be having the effect of my prostate cancer
progression. And I am now looking at other technologies and
clinics where I can rip things up to manage my condition and
new ways. So Dr. Teddett's book is a great book, Healied
with Voltage. I'm very familiar with it. I've been I've talked to
him in the past. Actually was going to interview him on one of
my podcasts and a number of years ago. And somehow the timing
didn't work when we didn't get back together. I think that
was right, but COVID hit. I actually have one of his bio
modulators. And I do agree that there's there's no argument
from a physiology and a physics standpoint that all your cells
have a cell charge is actually held in a cell membrane. And it
can be measured. Your he uses his bio modulator to measure
charge. There's some disagreement whether that is an accurate
measurement of cell charge B. But I think it's a beneficial
measurement. The way that is typically agreed upon by
scientists to measure cell charge is with a different
measurement device. And if you anybody on this call is ever
been to our office when we used to have patients in office, we
used to measure them with by putting little electrodes on
their hands and on their feet and measuring the impedance
called a bio impedance test. And it gives what's called a phase
angle. And that is a clinically relevant test. There's a lot
of research on phase angle. And that bio impedance across cell
membranes to measure cell membrane help. His bio modulator is
like a teeny mini PMF device. You don't feel any tingle. Like I
said, I have one personally, if someone ever said, and this
question has been asked over the years, should I get a
bio modulator from Dr. Tendon? Now, understand I love Dr.
Tendon? He's a great Christian man. I really do like him and
his and all the work that he does. But I personally would not
buy a bio modulator for treatment. You can get much greater
treatment and improving cell membrane health by using
PMF. So when he came up with the bio modulator, PMF was just
starting up and just coming out. They were very, very
expensive devices. They're still expensive devices. But doing
biting a clinic near you that does PMF, if purchasing a
PMF is out of the budget, because they're about $8,000, so they're
pretty expensive devices as well. But a PMF is a much better
tool to increase cell charge and increase health than the
bio modulator is. So if you can do that, now in truth, the
right does more than the bio modulator, it is increasing
cell charge. But the right doesn't do as much as a PMF increasing
cell charge. The PMF does nothing to kill cancer. But so either
one of the PMF door the bio modulator card our kids are killing
device. They're working just to work on cell charge. So cell
charge is a real thing that's measured again, in a device
called a bio impedance testing machine that it's testing or
phase angle, phase angle is measurable device measurable, objective
meter to see the health of a person not specific to cancer, but
specific to overall health person's phase angle is dropping
over time. They're their health is decreasing over that same
time period. All right. So there's other things that I would
suggest if a person's taking up, well, my markers are getting
worse. I've been doing the right. What else should I be doing?
Well, my question would be, are you doing all your supplements?
Are you doing your nutrition? Are you dealing with the psychology
and the spiritual aspect of your healing? You know, what
other? Yes, I'm doing all of that. What else could I do? Well,
there are other things devices that you could do other therapies
that you could do. Are you doing copy elements? One of the
greatest things to help decrease sympathetic drive and increase
parasympathetic stimulation and your vagal nerve over your
parasympathetics are what stimulate your immune function to
be able to kill cancer cells? Also, are you doing a casserole
packs up your liver? Are you working on detoxification pathways?
You know, so there's, you know, there's a list of different
things that you could go down and do without jumping in to
bite another piece of equipment. But there's also things that
you could do in other clinics near you too, possibly a
vitamin C, high dose vitamin C IVs that we've discussed at
depth of these zoom calls. There's, uh, making it so does that
you could do that could help you detox. So there's a lot of
different things that a person could do. So feel free to
schedule and tell them that we can talk about options for you
specifically. Things are not going the way you want.